the most senior Catholic cleric ever to
be convicted of child sexual abuse
received a six year prison sentence in
Australia this morning
a jury found Cardinal George Pell guilty
of molesting two choir boys more than 20
years ago Seth Doane is outside the
Vatican with the downfall of one of the
church's most powerful officials Seth
good morning good morning Cardinal Pell
faced up to 50 years behind bars for
five counts of child sex abuse the
Vatican has not yet made any official
comment but they are running their own
investigation in Australia outside the
court
protesters denounced Pell and the
Catholic Church Pell appeared at the
sentencing in an open shirt without the
customary collar of a Catholic priest
Chief Judge Peter Kidd said Pell
conducted himself with staggering
arrogance but explained he directed the
jury not to make the Cardinal a
scapegoat for any perceived failings of
the Catholic Church the judge also noted
that he saw no evidence of remorse the
Cardinal maintains his innocence and his
legal team will appeal the conviction
the 77 year old would be eligible for
parole after three years and eight
months one of Pels victims said he did
not take any comfort in the sentence in
a us-based victim's adversity advocacy
group that supports those who have been
victims of clerical sex abuse said that
they were disappointed in the
comparatively light sentence
Gail Seth Doane reporting from Rome
thank you